turkey is set to take a new step forward
in its quest to join the european union
at the general affairs council in
luxembourg on the 22nd of october
ministers are likely to confirm that
turkey can open a new chapter in its eu
accession negotiations
in all candidates must fulfill
requirements in 35 chapters or policy
areas so far turkey has opened 13.
the last chapter was opened more than
three years ago the council is also
expected to set a date for the accession
conference which will focus on chapter
22 regional policy and coordination of
structural instruments
turkey began its membership negotiations
in 2005.
the ministers will also discuss
preparations for the european council of
heads of state and government later in
the week
key items on the summit agenda include
the completion of the digital single
market youth unemployment and investment
as well as progress on strengthening
policies underpinning the euro single
currency and completing the banking
union
preparations for the eastern partnership
summit in lithuania at the end of next
month and the plight of asylum seekers
trying to cross the mediterranean to
europe will also be discussed
the ministers are also likely to endorse
a report on the european semester
process which helps member states to
better organize their budgets and
economic policies
the current cycle ended in july and the
next is due to commence in november when
the european commission publishes its
annual growth survey